i guess the question ahead is uh
you know how does a person like me or
general people discover
more productive uh you know languages
like how i was as i've been telling you
offline i've been looking for like a
project to work on in swift
so i can really uh try it out i mean
my intuition was like doing a hello
world is not going to get me there
uh to get me to experience the power of
the language
you need a few weeks to change your
metabolism exactly
beautifully put that that's one of the
problems with people with diets like i
i'm actually currently to go in parallel
but a small tangent is
i've been recently eating only meat okay
okay
and okay so most people are like
uh the thing that's horribly unhealthy
or whatever you have like a million
it whatever the science is it just
doesn't sound right
well so so back when i was in college we
did the atkins diet that was
that was a thing similar and but if you
you have to always give these things a
chance
i mean with dieting always not dieting
but it's just
the things that you like if i eat
personally if i eat meat
just everything i could be super [ __ ] or
more focused than usual
i just feel great i've been i've been
running a lot but you know doing
push-ups and posts and so on
i mean python is similar in that sense
for me where are you going with that
i mean literally i just i felt i had
like a stupid smile on my face when i
first started yeah
using python i could uh code up really
quick things like i like i would see the
world
i'll be empowered to write a script to
to um
you know to do some basic data
processing to rename files on my
computer yeah
right like pearl didn't do that for me
uh
any kind a little bit well and again
like no these are about which which is
best or something like that but there's
definitely better and worse here but it
clicks
right well yeah and if you if you look
at pearl for example you get bogged down
in
uh scalars versus arrays versus hashes
versus type globs and like all that kind
of stuff and
and python's like yeah let's not do this
right and some of it is debugging like
everyone has different priorities but
for me it's can i create systems for
myself that
empower me to debug quickly like i've
always been
a big fan even just crude like asserts
like always
uh stating things that should be true
which in python i found in myself doing
more because of type
all these kinds of stuff well you could
think of types in a programming language
as being kind of a sort
yeah they could check to compile time
right um
so how do you learn anything well so
this or how do people learn new things
right this this is hard
uh people don't like to change people
generally don't like change around them
either
and so uh we're all very slow to adapt
and change and
usually there's a catalyst that's
required to force yourself over the over
over this so for learning a programming
language it really comes down to finding
an excuse like build a thing that that's
that the language is actually good for
that the ecosystem is ready for
um and so um and so if you were to write
an ios app for example that would be the
easy case
obviously you would you would use swift
for that right there are other android
uh swift runs on android oh does it oh
yeah
yeah that's what friends and lots of
devices so uh
okay so swift swift is built on top of
llvm
the lvm runs everywhere lvm for example
builds the android kernel
oh wow okay so yeah um that's so i
didn't realize this
yeah so swift swift is very portable
runs on windows there's
it runs on lots of different things and
uh side interrupts
ui and then there's a thing called ui
kit
so can i build an app with swift uh
well so that's the thing is the
ecosystem is what matters there so
swift ui and ui kit are apple
technologies okay got it and so they
happen to like swift ui happens to be
written in swift but it's an apple
proprietary framework that um apple
loves and wants to keep on its platform
which makes total sense
you go go to android and you don't have
that library yeah right and so
android has a different ecosystem of
things that hasn't been built out and
doesn't work as well with swift and so
you can totally use swift to do like
arithmetic and things like this but
building ui with swift on android is not
not not a not a great example it's right
now
so so if i wanted to uh to learn swift
what's the
pro i mean the one practical different
version of that is uh
swift for tensorflow for example and one
of the inspiring things for me
with both tensorflow and pytorch is how
quickly the community can like
switch from different libraries like
you could see some of the community
switching to pytorch now
but it could it's very easy to see and
then tensorflow is really stepping up
its game
and then there's no reason why i think
it the way it works is basically it has
to be one github repo like one paper
steps up
gets people excited it gets people
excited and they're like ah i have to
learn this
at swift for what what swift again yeah
and then they learn and they fall in
love with it i mean that's what happened
by torch has a there has to be a reason
a catalyst
yeah and so and and there i mean
people don't like change but it turns
out that once you've worked with one or
two programming languages there
the basics are pretty similar and so one
of the fun things about learning
programming languages
even even maybe lisp i don't know if you
agree with this is that
when you start doing that you start
learning new things
because you have a new way to do things
and you're forced to do them and that
forces you
to explore and it puts you in learning
mode and when you get in learning mode
your mind kind of opens a little bit and
you can
you can see things in a new way even
when you go back to the old place
you